So here's some fairly unconventional advice.
I think that if you are really struggling with a course or failing it then either that
subject matter really isn't for you or you need to get better friends. And often
I think that last part getting better friends is pretty much what it comes down to.
The advice that I'm going to talk about mainly applies for
university level subjects and my experience in studying at University and how to get good grades there
But I think this probably applies at school as well
I think it's almost kind of obvious at that level that if you're friends with people that
are sort of leading you astray things aren't going to work out well for you.
But I'm more talking about people that are actually, you know, really keen to study really came to get good grades
But for some reason they just don't and this phrase "if you get bad grades
you need better friends" isn't actually something I came up with myself.
It's something that I heard a professor telling to the students in his class.
So at that level, I guess the professor wanted the students to learn and do well
but he was aware enough that I guess there was a lot of material to learn and that
For student trying to learn at all on their own
they're just not going to do as well as someone who's
going about it a bit smarter and is working with other people. And
When I say working with other people, of course, I'm not talking about
copying off people or like not learning the content for yourself, but doing it smartly
working in teams to figure out problems that alone would have
taken you way too long to figure out like you can actually use other people
To your advantage in a way that benefits all of you.
Of course again, there are situations when you can't work with other people at universities. So on take-home tests or exams or
assessed work. But for assignments and studying and all that sort of stuff
it's kind of expected that you would work with someone.
It's it's not expected that someone's going to be able to learn all the course content and do all the assignments like purely on their
own. I don't think that's a smart thing to do at all. So the way I see it is that
actually, if you're studying at University, then the most important skill that's going to help you get good grades is being able to socialise and
being able to make friends with strangers and and communicate and work in a team. Now
I know that
for like a lot of you guys study maths or physics that subject like that because that's what I talk about on my channel and
Often socializing isn't our most favorite activity. In fact, I in person
I'm an incredibly shy and socially awkward person.
So if someone gave me this advice ages ago, it would probably horrify me and I would say no.
Learning physics shouldn't be about how good you are at socializing
it should be all about your inherent
mathematical skills and you should be able to be like that lone genius and and you would think like
Einstein never had to work in a team
He just came up with all these theories on his own. But you know like I've been through the Uni system
And I've sort of seen how this works and I've come to the realization that there is no such thing as the lone genius.
But that's sort of a whole nother topic
Essentially the way that a lot of Unis work in the way at least mine definitely did was
to get the most out of the course and to get the most out of what the lecturer is offering you and and all the
Opportunities available to you, you really need to work with other people and if you don't have friends in a class
It's going to be really hard for you no matter how smart you think you are.
So my biggest study tip is to find some friends early in your course and
you know, if you don't know how to find friends, here's some ideas like
the
most valuable friends
I guess I made at university were the people that I met in like the front row of lectures
it seems to be then the people that sit in the front row are like really keen and
often really friendly really open to like
I don't know working together and and having chats about the content and I think in the front row of lectures you can find some
really valuable people.
I think uni and finding friends is always harder for people that don't live on campus and don't have that sort of
automatic friend group that comes along with living with other people, but I think it really is possible to meet friends and lectures
It can be as easy as just like asking them what their major is and then asking them
You know about some assignment you have guys have coming up whether they like to work together and the more
Momentum you can build around sort of a study group and add more people into it and really build that
family and that sense of belonging and and
Comradeship around your course, it's gonna be a lot better for you.
So let me give you some examples from my life and what I'm talking about here.
Now today is actually my 23rd birthday and it's the anniversary of a time back in first year when I spent my birthday
having a real miserable time in a mathematical modelling lab. It was an 8 a.m
Lab on a Friday and I mean that timing is awful about why this was a really awful day for me
was because I just had no friends in this class.
I guess the content wasn't even that difficult. I remember this particular lab. We were on MATLAB and we were like trying to
code in some functions to
generate trig functions like the sine function
through a Taylor expansion.
We were coding it and I feel like this would kind of be really easy for me to do now
It's not even hard in concept, but at the time I just had like no idea what I was doing.
I didn't know how to use MATLAB
I didn't know anything about Taylor expansion
but I also just had no friends in this class and it was the only class like this because
It was the only class I was taking different to like my main
group of solid friends who I'd made in my other courses and I was just like sitting in this room and
everyone felt really unapproachable. I didn't know anyone and I just felt like I had to struggle through it alone.
And I was like, that's fine. I can just like read up, you know explanations for this and try and figure it out myself, but
Honestly, it was just miserable. I took so long to try and figure it out
and if I just had someone beside me who I felt comfortable like talking to and being like oh
Are you up to this step? How do you think we go from here?
It just would have been so much better and it was actually after I had such a bad time in that course.
But I was like, I'm never gonna let that happen again
I'm always going to make sure you know in the first week of a new course
My priority is going to be making sure I have a friend in this class like that
I know someone and that I can I can always ask someone for help and I think that was really so important for me was
prioritizing
not letting myself be alone and struggling alone in a course.
The way that I would work with my friends who I made in classes that maybe we'd like sit together in lectures and
maybe joke around a little bit or like talk about around them stuff
But then like when it came to doing assignments often
There would be like facebook messenger chats or groups or something and that would be like, you know
How do you do this
certain type of
question? And then people would sort of explain it to you. And and it really worked both ways because if you were struggling with something
You could ask
Your friends for help and they would often, you know, get you out of the rut
You're in much faster than you could get out yourself.
But also if you are the person who already understands what's going on
and you'd probably could just do this particular assignment all by yourself no worries
I think it's really valuable for you to help other people out and to not be a jerk but to
You know, really
Bring people along with you.
And I think it really benefits you because you are getting practice explaining something and you're actually making sure you understand it better yourself
You're solidifying things and you've got these people who sort of like are really grateful for your help.
So I really think it goes both ways.
If you're struggling in class make it your priority to make good friends
and people that you know are aligned with what you're trying to achieve in the class and
Aren't going to drag you down and are really going to help you get there
And even if you are doing really well
Maybe go out of your way a little bit to help others to still
appreciate the value of friends when you're studying and to know that it also values you to explain things to other people.
Thanks for watching.